everybody what is going on welcome to
another OpenGL with Python and PI game
and all that fun stuff tutorial video
this video what I want to be showing you
guys how we can sort of navigate around
this cube using user key presses so one
of the reasons why people use it with Pi
game so often is PI game has a lot of
built-in functionality around user input
and displaying those changes so when you
slap OpenGL and into the picture it's
relatively simple to kind of throw an
OpenGL for the graphic stuff but keep
kind of back-end with PI game so that's
what I'll be showing you guys now so the
first thing we'll do is we'll we'll X
out of this fancy spinning cube and then
let's go ahead and stop the cube from
spinning
so we'll comment out in this main
function here we're going to come out
comment out gl rotate the first one
we'll leave this or I mean the second
one rather the one that's in the wild
true loop we'll leave that one there so
now our cube looks like this okay so
we're kind of over a little bit and just
looking at our cubes so now what close
out of this fancy and now we're going to
throw in some typical PI game stuff so
for those of you who are familiar with
PI game um this should look pretty
typical to you for those of you who are
not familiar with PI game um I guess
just follow along if you want to know
more check out the PI game tutorial
series so ah this is our event loop
right so for event plugin event I get
this is just any event that occurs so if
you're not if you haven't watched the PI
game series this is like where is the
mouse is the mouse clicking what keys
are being pressed is is this window even
an active window for the user all that
stuff is being captured in these PI game
events so the first event is if it's a
PI game quit the next one we're going to
ask for is if it's a key press so we can
do something like this if event type
equals PI game dot a key down what do we
want so if the event
key equals PI game dot K underscore left
that is a left arrow key so if that's
the case then we're going to do a GL
translate well we've we've done this
before right this is right here GL
translate so let's copy that and let's
paste it here now what was this
translate remember this was the Z
variable so let's make that zero and if
we press the we press the left key we
want to move like side to side so what
would we put here for X well we want to
move left
so what direction on that is x axis we
want to move well we want to move left
that's a negative movement on the x axis
so that would be a negative one then
we're going to say basically let's just
copy this copy that paste and then
instead of K left let's say K right and
then set negative 1 it's a 1 easy now
let's save and run that up pops our game
now when we press the key you can see
we're moving around the cube now we were
obviously moving quite a bit so first of
all we could move back a little bit like
negative 10 let's see about that
so the cubes a little further so now we
have a little bit more space to like
move around the cube you could also make
the movements less right so we're using
one like a whole unit move but we could
all obviously do minus 0.5 and then 0.5
something like that and that would make
it a little bit less of a move each time
and you can obviously do 0.1 and so on
so we'll close out of that and now we
can do the same thing for up and down
right we can use the key up and key down
so let's just let's copy this come down
here well paste instead of key right we
want key up and then this can be a zero
and then for up we want to move up on a
y-axis now this is a little different
than what you're going to be used to
with PI game but just go with me we'll
put a 1 there and then we'll copy this
paste and now it's going to be K
underscore down and we'll make that
negative one movement so let's save and
run that again and now we move up down
left right diagonally you get the point
we're moving about the cube now there's
one more movement that we have yet to
cover and that's zoom so how do we zoom
in and out of the cube well that's a
little bit more tricky but we're going
to use the mouse wheel for that and
actually in all of my pot game tutorials
we have not covered the mass wheel
movement simply because the main purpose
for rolling the wheel is for zoom so
here it is for you fine folks so um the
next thing we're going to say this is
not a key press right the mouse wheel
movement isn't an official key down it's
it's a mouse movement and then as I if
you did fall in the Pi game tutorial
series we learn that really the mouse
presses there's only a one there's only
three right you've got the left press
you've got the press of the mouse wheel
and then you got right click but a mass
wheels it's like its own thing entirely
so this one will be if event dot type
equals Pi game dot all caps mouse button
down if it's a mouse button down that
means the wheel is a rolling okay so and
if it's rolling forward it is a four and
if it's rolling in Reverse it is
classified as a five so all we would do
at this point is we would say if event
dot button equals four then we'll run a
translate let's just copy and paste one
of these so we'll copy and paste we'll
make this a zero and we said four four
is forward so four would be one point
zero let's say so we're going to move
forward one unit and then we can copy
and paste this copy come down here paste
and we'll say now if event button is a
five what do we want to do we want to
move backwards of unit so we'll do that
now I'll save it run that and now when
we roll our mouse you'll see that we're
zooming
towards an or away from the cube we can
make it go all the way away and then
obviously and this is in in relation to
where the cube is to us so we could put
it down here no problem and it's clearly
like zooming under us you know oh I've
lost it
I lost the cube okay let me bring it
back anyway so yeah so there it is we
can move it over here and that's why
like this kind of stuff start is why
using someone else's 3d environment is
much easier oh and we hadn't talked
about clipping planes that just reminded
me so you see how it just like
disappears out you know the back that's
because of the clipping plane so let's
talk about clipping plane so I had
mentioned it I think on the first OpenGL
video and that's these numbers here
right this is Z near Z far this is the
closer clipping plane this is the
further clipping plane and then I was
like what the hell are clipping planes
right so here's our cube and then you
know you can go back and forth and the
clipping plane basically means well this
is a close one so at what point are we
going to stop showing the object so
let's say the clipping plane is three
and actually let's make the clipping
plane like six and then we'll make this
clipping plane twenty third twenty five
we'll make it 20 that'll do so this
clipping plane from our perspective six
points out it will stop showing the cube
not quite enough will will knock it off
a little bit but you can't you should
already be seeing as you're zooming and
it's just chipping things away and then
outwards as we scroll out it just
disappears eventually and that's because
of the far clipping plane so it's like
it's too far for us to be in view so
we'll get rid of it
so we can make this you know a ten we
can make this a seven maybe that might
be easier yes so like you can see it
like totally disappeared because of the
clipping plane and then same thing there
so this plane is in theory ten units out
is the far clipping plane so this the
rest of this cube is more than ten units
away and then here we can zoom it in
and this cube for the most part all
these parts of the cube are in our close
enough to our what was it a seven yeah
seven units out clipping plane so
anyways um hopefully it also this is
going to vary depending on like where we
are in relation to the cube so obviously
like here we are much closer to the cube
as far as like relation to the cube and
you can see it disappears much earlier
than it had when we were say like above
the cube like this I suppose like it's
almost off of the screen so it's really
good about perspective anyway um that
covers it again I would just make your
clipping plane like 0.1 and then like 50
or something so it has plenty of room to
move about so 50 lets us go pretty far
back there before it disappears it just
really depends on like what your use
actually is as far as where you're going
to put it but anyway that's going to
conclude this video in the next incoming
videos we're going to attempt to make a
game out of this so our first game was a
2d kind of object avoidance game I see
no reason why we can't now have a 3d
object avoidance game where we're trying
to avoid these nasty deadly cubes from
hitting us so anyways that's what you
guys have to look forward to so
hopefully you're excited um if you guys
have any questions or comments please
feel free to leave them in the section
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching thank you for all of your
support and subscriptions and until next
time